your album country against side a i
listened to some of the songs and this
really is a journey of you being a son
a father a husband it is absolutely
beautiful so what does it mean
to be country again you know i've been
playing around with these words lately
and i think that the word country can
mean so many things
you know and i think my favorite synonym
of the word would be simple
and you know over the last couple years
i mean especially over the last decade
i've been doing this for 10 years which
seems crazy
um but i think you can get into these
grinds in your life where you are
you're putting so much weight in your
success
you know what i mean like you're always
looking to the next thing you do
something cool
and it's over and you do something else
and i think these last two years have
taught me how to like take moments that
are awesome
and and really just celebrate them like
you just said you know like actually
making time to get people over to the
house
have a cookout and celebrate something
awesome that just happened and
you know for me i guess since early 2019
i think i've just been living so much
more simple
you know things that i used to put so
much weight in just don't hold the same
weight anymore and
i looked right in front of me and i was
like i have the most amazing wife and
kids in the world
these are this is the priority you know
and when i started to
let that kind of lead my life um
these songs just kind of fell out of me
and uh it was it was a really really
cool moment in my life and then and
something that i hope
extends through the entirety of my life
so yeah and it's interesting like i
think you mentioned the fact that you
have this epiphany in 2019
this happens in 2020 you kind of have
that reflection but what did you learn
about yourself that you didn't know
before
through this time you know i think
there's so many things from like
childhood um and uh even high school and
college that i
that i'd used to love you know whether
it was like camping or
fly fishing or you know just even just
the art of building a fire
you know what i mean there was something
about this this pandemic that you know
you kind of got to get creative
you know with what you're what you're
doing because it can you can easily
put yourself into boredom uh and so for
me and the girls we just we just found
ourselves getting outside a lot you know
i'm just reminded how much i love the
outdoors
and you know how much peace it brings us
and and uh just being in the sun
you know what i'm saying like there's
just something awesome about being in
the sun
and uh you know so for me there's a
quote in this book i've been reading it
was like give yourself permission to be
young
and i just you know just started to live
by that
you know like even when the kids wanted
to go outside when it's raining to stomp
in a mud puddle and get dirty i was like
absolutely let's go you know and um it
just led me to such a more
just peaceful way of living and and uh
that's kind of where the whole title
country again came from and really the
whole
record so you're in a good spot right
now aren't you
i feel good yeah yeah i could feel it
i could feel it and this is what this
album's all about too
we understand what's happening in side a
and this is a double album what can we
expect from side b
man i i wrote so many songs i mean i
probably wrote 200 songs from
2019 and now and so it was it was really
tough to whittle him down
you know i probably could have made five
records out of this but i i asked my 15
year old brother i said hey if i put
um 26 songs on a record would you get
bored and he said yes
and so that was when i decided to split
the two up and so
really side b is a continuation um but
it was tough to split them up because
there's there's five or six songs off
side b
that are literally some of my favorite
work i've ever been a part of so i
wanted to give people a chance to soak
inside a so that when side b
came out they were equally as excited
about both and then could put them
together and
you know listen to them as a whole so um
just a very singer songwriter
record you know i really just kind of do
and wrote what was on my heart
and hope people could relate so let's
talk about the writing because i know
you co-wrote some of the songs with your
dad
uh which is really exciting so how does
that process work does he come up with
an idea you come up with an idea do you
clash
or do you guys really work well together
we really do it's not it's not a joke we
he's like really my favorite person to
write with you know um
because as much as i think i know a lot
about me
he knows just as much you know what i'm
saying and to be able to put those two
brains together
is really neat so my dad toured with me
all 2019
he actually opened for us the whole year
so we did 65 dates together
and uh you know every day it was just
like well it's 10 30 you want to write a
song and it was like yeah
and you know so before we knew it we
were just writing two and three songs a
day and
you know getting to play some of them
live you know that night and uh
it was just a really neat experience my
dad is probably on
you know 16 or 17 of the 30s recorded so
he was a huge part in this in this
record making process
is he your best friend yeah one of them
for sure
um yeah i mean my dad and i have
you know obviously been super close my
whole life and
uh you know even from the time i was
young you know he was the he was my
my dad that was writing me doctor's
notes to help me get out of school on a
thursday so i'd come on the road with
him on the weekend and so
um we've always been partners in crime
together and and uh you know i just feel
like i've learned
so many of my life lessons from my dad
so
talking about life lessons the fact that
you were brought up in this world where
your dad's an
artist you kind of got exposed to it
you're kind of prepared for this world
but have you ever been overwhelmed by
the fame and success
um i don't know if overwhelmed is the
word i would say i've definitely felt
more pressure
you know um pressure to pressure to
perform
you know pressure to be on you know i
mean i know i understand some of that
you know you can
you could definitely be having a bad day
or uh just just have had a fight with
your with your wife or one of your best
friends and then you're walking on stage
and you're like hey what's up everybody
you know so
um you know those things took me a
minute to uh to kind of wrap my head
around but at the same time
i think i think people need honesty and
i think people need vulnerability from
from people that they
like their music from you know so i'm
not afraid to to say
you know if i'm having a rough day or if
i'm tired or something like that because
i think that's just a normal human thing
to be
it's tired and so that's so true
but i think you know lately um it's just
been really nice my wife put a book out
last year that was
went super super deep into our life and
in our marriage and
her childhood and and uh you know we've
kind of prided ourselves on
being overly vulnerable with people that
that want to hear what we have to say
you know because i think it can
really help people you know potentially
get through a time how to get through
without
reading some of that information so yeah
honesty is really powerful and let's
talk about honesty how has it been being
home with three little ones
under the age of five how are you coping
how is lauren coping
i can't even imagine it's it is absolute
insanity
all right yeah i mean
you know but but at the same time it's
like
you wouldn't trade that insanity for the
world you know like i posted something
on my instagram about a year ago my wife
and i snuck away down to the beach for a
weekend just us too
which is very needed you know if you
have kids you have to figure out time to
get away
um but i noticed like the first night
that we were at the beach
we were we got in the bed and i looked
at her and i was like
you kind of miss our kids you know and
and it's like she's like yeah i do you
know because
you're around it so much and you're used
to being in a house where people are
screaming all day long and
asking for something and when you
actually get a chance to stop for a
second you're like dang what do we do
you know like how do we how do we go to
dinner and what do we talk about
and and so that's that's been something
fun in our marriage is just to
just to kind of figure out new ways to
have date night you know and really just
try to
just have good conversation with each
other and share a meal or glass of wine
and really just get to unwind for a
minute but it's
it's been a nuts this is the longest
i've ever been at home in my life
um and so i'm kind of nervous to get
back on the road to be honest because i
you know now it's just complete brain
shift of back into what we were doing in
2019 so
but i wouldn't trade it for anything
it's been incredible just getting watch
them grow and and
get to be with them every step of the
way this year